so what he really wanted to do was paint
it turned out
and now he is hunter biden is selling
his paintings and they're so
good they're so unbelievable that people
are paying
up to half a million dollars to buy just
one their private galleries in new york
and la
according the washington post the white
house is helping him
they're his art dealer now they helped
hunter biden reach a deal to hide the
identities
of the people who bought those paintings
that doesn't sound corrupt or anything
miranda devine has reported extensively
on the biden family's business dealings
she's a columnist at the washington post
we're happy to have her now
so the white house is helping
the first son keep his art he's now an
artist has been for the last couple
weeks
keep his half million dollar art
transaction secret
what that just seems like flagrant
corruption to me
hi tucker i just wanted to say first
that um
you know express solidarity for you with
these nsa spying
problems i think every journalist in the
country should be up in arms
absolutely outrageous um so almost as
outrageous as
hunter biden's little art scam that the
white house is is trying to cover up for
him
it's crazy that they think
that somehow making the
transactions less transparent keeping
secret the
buyers of hunter biden's paintings and
their countries of origin somehow that
is going to solve the problem that
someone might be buying access to the
white house by
spending half a million dollars on one
of his paintings it's
it's crazy but at least you know the
good thing is that the white house
is talking about ethics now it's only
been nine months
since the new york post broke the story
uh about hunter biden's laptops and all
the
ethical at least uh infringements that
are
apparent there and that we've been
reporting on um but
it it sort of biggers belief that the
white house
thinks that they can just smoothly go
along
and in effect uh outsource
their ethics policy to some manhattan
art dealer mate of hunters
who um you know is supposed to somehow
vet
the these these buyers and you know
like somehow he he knows whether the
chinese guys
uh a member of the you know high-ranking
member of the chinese communist party or
or the russian is the associated with
the
former corrupt mayor of moscow or you
know some ukrainian
energy corrupt oligarch how does he know
he's not a
he's not a foreign policy expert or an
intelligence operative
so that's nuts in itself but the other
thing that's
mad is that they have you know
hunter and his mate have decided that
they're going to set the prices
of these paintings and they've put them
as we said
half a million dollars which is
outrageous for
a first-time painter as as beautiful as
hunter's
art is there was a picasso that was sold
this week it was
uncovered in a closet in in maine where
it had been sitting
for 30 years that went for 150 000
and hunter wants three times that so
don't think it works
i mean there's nothing sleazier than the
international art market i mean it's a
massive tax judge
i think you get a more straightforward
deal with the drug cartels at least they
know who they are
you know it's like the whole thing is
it's unbelievable to me
miranda divine from the new york post
not jeff bezos washington but just want
to be completely clear
thank you great to see you good thanks
tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else